faces covered protesters hurled missiles
at police on the streets of the Peruvian
capital
they in turn fired tear gas back
the demonstration spread to Lima on
Thursday with injuries on both sides
as thousands poured into the city many
from remote and Dayan regions demanding
the resignation of President Dina
boluati
disturbances forced members of the
public to flee the burning tear gas
while tanks waited on standby
to those who are protesting daily who is
financing you why are you not working
and what money are you bringing to your
homes what you want to do is create
chaos and disorder and amid that chaos
and disorder take over the control of
the country
the protests began weeks ago after
president boloati was sworn in on
December the 7th following the arrests
and impeachment of her predecessor Pedro
Castillo he was ousted after announcing
plans to dissolve Congress and install
an emergency government but until the
past few days the protests have focused
further south with more than 50 kills in
violent clashes
among the affected areas the city of
arequipa which has again become the
focus for demonstrations with the two
sides divided by makeshift blockades
and in the Cusco region operations were
suspended at one of the country's
largest copper mines on Friday after
protesters attacked the premises for the
third time this month
but the focus shifting to the capital
marks a new phase in The Descent
prompting the president to vow to get
tough on those she called vandals after
an unexplained fire at one of Lima's
most historic buildings it's up the
night sky
but it seems little will stop the
protesters until she resigns and fresh
elections are called
Emma virtually Sky News